[Música]
eu adoro medindo coisas ea razão porque
eu adoro me de coisas é porque eu sou
cientista os cientistas usam réguas para
medir e compreender a natureza são
muitas retas no cotidiano
usamos o metro e para olhar o método
colocamos os nossos focos da mecânica
clássica mas márcia para medir muito
longe e como é que se faz para medir as
distâncias entre o sol e as estrelas às
galáxias
usamos um ano nos que a distância que a
luz percorre um ano que o pequenininho
hora para medir as distâncias dos atos
utilizamos o ano
[Música]
neste mundo do mundo um mundo e
utilizamos nossos novos plantios
como vocês vêem toda pessoa elegante
física tem no mínimo três jogos um
clássico para o dia a dia um cântico
para essas coisinhas pequenas e
relativístico para o distante para os
grandes eventos que duram tão pouco
parece fácil né infelizmente a vida não
é tão fácil
existe uma distância o nome tu não é
querer se com queira mas ora é clássico
ora é quântico mas mais do que é o nono
olá metro é dez vezes maior que o anos o
pai tão grande nem tanto se vocês
pegarem um fio de cabelo a espessura de
um fio de cabelo e partir em 60 mil
vezes vai dar um nó a então ele é
pequeno mas também é grande por isso que
ora clássico
ora quântico e o interessante é que essa
distância é essa dimensão ela é muito
contra intuitiva
ela cria fenômenos que fogem à nossa
intuição
deixa eu dar um exemplo de um fenômeno
muito antigo 15 ocorre na distância
nanométrica
os romanos no século 4 portanto muito
antigamente se fabricaram o cálice de
licores e cicalise tem a característica
inusitada de quando iluminado por trás é
vermelho e pela frente é verde uma
espécie de melancia cais
esse cálice é feito de vidro e nós
sabemos que o vidro o é translúcido
quase uma cor como é que pode ter esse
comportamento verde e vermelho
o comportamento do cálice de licurgo só
foi conhecido no saco leite
quando os cientistas mergulharam na
escala nanométrica e descobriram que
misturado com a sílica que é ouvido
existe não partículas de ouro e de prata
em pequeníssima quantidade que
provocavam esse efeito fascinante
não é lindo em ser feito é muito
bonitinho bonitinho ordinária porque não
serve pra nada
aí vocês vão perguntar mas márcia tem
nada na natureza contra o efetivo
nanométrico que sirva para alguma coisa
e obviamente a resposta é sim senão não
estaria aqui deixa mostrar pra vocês a
folha de lopes
a folha de lótus tem característica que
a água quando se move sobre essa folha
se move rapidamente e se vocês colocarem
dentro em cima da folha depois que a
água passou a apoia está seca
essa rapidez da água silva vê que o fato
dela nunca se molhar
tem características clássicas
característica clássica se a gente olhar
bem de pertinho a superfície da folha de
lótus
a gente vai notar que ela enche de umas
gotinhas um como se fosse uns curtos
a água se fecha como se a gente tivesse
deitado numa cama de pregos não querendo
tocar os prédios
isso no entanto não consegue explicar
por que que a campanha nunca morre
para entender por que a folha nunca olha
eu convido vocês a mergulhar na escala
nanométrica
a superfície de cada curucutu é coberta
por um material que odeia a odeon e água
como se materiais em sentimentos pois é
a materiais que tenham água materiais
que amam a e essa característica de amor
e ódio recíproco não se peru não se
preocupem água também odeia o material
que eu dei a ela ama quem ama é e essa
característica quântica
então a fuga de lótus consegue ter essa
rapidez e nunca olhar porque tem na
estruturas que odeiam a os cientistas
desenvolveram nano estruturas
semelhantes que cobre diversos materiais
que se tomam completamente em perm a e
aí a gente consegue ter no sofá da casa
da gente um material que não vai olhar
quando a gente derramar uma com um
cálice de vinho uma cerveja ou uma coca
cola mas eu posso fazer coisas ontem com
materiais que odeiam a água será que eu
não consigo fazer algo útil com
materiais que amam a água assim como
folha de lótus
é a água e consegue essa mobilidade
impermeabilidade existe uma planta
chamada cúpula phalanx que na pontinha
das folhas têm um material que ama mas
ama mesmo não tipo ficante de festa uma
tipo casar para viver os resto da vida
juntos 40 anos de casados
ela ama tanto a água que ela transforma
o vapor da água da manhã do deserto que
aonde a cúpula phalanx bi em água liga
então tem vapor de água totta a pontinha
da folha virá a água líquida
isso é fantástico mas seria um tremendo
desastre se ela fosse coletando água
coletando água fizesse uma boca enorme e
por gravidade caísse longe da planta
a natureza foi muito esperta embaixo
dessa plantinha que coleta água
desenvolvido na cultura tê-las uma rede
de um material que odeia como se a
cultura transformar-se vapor de água em
água líquida e tivesse o seu próprio
reservatório para armazenar a essa
planta combina amor e ódio para poder
captar a água e com isso armazenar e ter
água líquida brasília
quando vim pela primeira vez eu pensei
márcia
será que não é possível usá esse amor e
ódio da cultura phalanx para termos mais
água potável no planeta
eles vão dizer pra quê nada potável
eu abro a torneira em casa sempre tem
água pois é no mundo hoje nós temos
falta de água
uma em cada seis pessoas do planeta vive
numa região de trânsito que mesmo no
brasil onde a gente tem essa abundância
de água existem regiões aonde a falta de
água uma alternativa para essa falta de
ar
é o mar para utilizar a água do mar no
entanto a gente tem que remover o sal
porque nós não podemos consumir água
salgada e nem utilizá-la para plantar e
sal infelizmente é uma destas partículas
que amam a água então custa muita
energia separar o sal da água
a estratégia que se usa hoje no mundo
para fazer isso é pegar uma grande
membrana fazer um pequeno furo nessa
membrana e empurra com muita força o sal
ea água como a água é uma molécula
pequena ela passa eu sal passa com mais
dificuldade como sempre passa um pouco
de salto tem que repetir esse processo
inúmeras vezes o que faz o processo de
dessalinização segundo carro
as plantas os cejas as estruturas que
fazem a destabilização do mundo que são
comuns em países que não têm nenhuma
água potável são grandes estruturas são
enormes edifícios porque você tem que
fazer esse processo de paz a água e
inúmeras vez e isso é muito caro
o meu grupo de pesquisa pesquisa
maneiras inovadoras de separar o sal da
nossa estratégia e olhar propriedades
contra impeditivas da água a usá las
para fazer isso contributivas márcia mah
sabotam comum pois é a água possui mais
de 70 propriedades contra em coletivas
ela é bem maluquinha mesmo uma dessas
propriedades
o nosso grupo de pesquisa de física
computacional descobriu alguns anos
atrás e é o seguinte se você coloca
todas as moléculas de água muito
próximas no agrupamento
aproximar vem muito rapidamente
sim você entender vultos moléculas de
água e cada molécula se move mais
depressa
nós descobrimos que a água fazia isso
porque ela se liga e desliga nas
moléculas vizinhas como se uma multidão
de pessoas para se mover mais
rapidamente as pessoas fossem se
agarrando nos no ombro uma das ruas por
favor não façam isso porque não vai dar
certo
depois a gente percebeu que se eu agora
pegasse essa habilidade de se mover
muito rápido da água e confinar se ela
no tubo de carbono carbono um material
que odeia água as partículas de água não
se mover muito rápido ela se informasse
leira que iria barrar up da mente como
se fosse um bloco de carnaval do meio da
multidão que iria se movendo
essa propriedade ela é tão interessante
porque enquanto a água simone
rapidamente dentro desse tubo o sal
simplesmente não entra
e ele não entra porque o sol que ficar
do lado de fora odiando de moléculas de
água quando ele vê aquela abertura
pequena a única maneira da partícula de
sal entrar e removendo camada de água e
ele não quer você isso é como se um dia
frio alguém me dissesse massa entra por
aquela porta mas para entrar lá tem que
tirar o casaco
eu não sei vocês eu não tiro o meu
casaco em dias frios e o sol não entra
quando a gente descobriu isso eu disse
nossa vamos fazer um filtro com milhões
de nanotubos de carbono
vamos empurrar sal e água o sal não
entra de jeito nenhum e agente numa
única passada de salina água do mar
estava muito contente
infelizmente a vida é um pouco mais
complicado
nanotubos de carbono são tóxicos exige
uma no tubo desses ou
a cidh o filtro contaminasse a água e
alguém respirasse no topo isso poderia
afetar a saúde das pessoas
eu fiquei muito desapontado
pensei o que eu vou fazer agora foi aí
que eu li o artigo sobre a cultura falar
de amor e ódio e pensei será que eu não
posso usar a mesma idéia da cúpula
phalanx para desenvolver um filtro que
tenha um furo pequeno que o sol fica do
lado de fora mas que ao mesmo tempo seja
seguro ea resposta para essa pergunta é
sim um filtro que a gente escolheu foi
de um material chamado de sulfeto de
molibdênio o desenvolvimento de
molibdênio e forma uma membrana em que
ele vai ter uma tarefa de enxofre uma
carga de molibdênio e uma outra carga de
enxofre
nós fizemos um nano poro nesse nessa
membrana ea água que está lá no meio do
sal feliz da vida porque ela é um sal
ela dá aquela é a dela e viu enxofre que
tentar a água e meio promíscua
ela olha e se joga nos braços do enxofre
seria uma tragédia se ela ficasse lá no
enxofre não passasse por outro lado da
membrana
mas como ela é muito político ela já
olha vê o molibdênio que tem até cada
dupla e aí se joga nos braços do
molibdênio se joga nos braços do enxofre
pronto ela está lá do outro lado da
membrana e o sal ficou do lado de carro
segundo os nossos cálculos
computacionais esse processo quando
implementado sob a forma de uma membrana
vai reduzir em dez vezes o tamanho de
uma planta de digitalização legal não é
por isso que eu acredito que o futuro
está na nano escala ela se contra
intuitiva por misturar o clássico eo
quântico permite que a gente desenvolva
novas idéias
ela combina
na folha de lótus os curtos clássicos
com o ódio a água que atlântico ela
combina cultura phalanx o ódio o amor
para produzir não só a sílaba como
reservar a nós também temos que usar
como a natureza e se escala brincalhona
para resolver não só o problema de falta
de água mas tantos outros problemas
é isso que o grupo faz ozanan na escala
para poder deslizar essa tecnologia está
agora sendo aprimorada para que possa
chegar segura e eficiente às nossas
casas
enquanto isso não acontece o desafio
vocês
há também procurar coisas interessantes
e contra impeditivas na nano escala para
resolver os problemas do mundo pense
grande
pense nada
[Música]
[Aplausos]